lamar got a gear not many human beings
gap game recognized game no he the og
superman
for him to be as successful and to make
the impact the big splash in
in this game you know not many people
have done it you know i say michael vick
i say lamar
you know i
you know i don't even think i'm in that
in that in that stratosphere i watched
campuses uh
you know um everyone in the country did
everyone know about cam superman
you know doing doing his thing you know
um and a lot of us looked up to him um
he's a mobile quarterback um he do his
thing he's he's a person who has who has
took this
this league by storm
and especially
you know early on the doubt that came
with it i mean i we all can relate to
you know being
a second guest question can he play he
got bus written all over and things like
that for him to succeed through it all
you know makes him the true underdog
story that we all love to root for
cam newton lamar jackson
sharing uh appreciation for each other
and look two of the best quarterbacks in
the nfl getting together sunday night
nbc
mvp last year lamar jackson mvp 2015 cam
newton peter i i agree with everything
these guys are saying
i i just i wish cam newton hadn't missed
the time that he missed because to me
that felt like the moment that you know
what they were building just completely
fell apart new england and they've been
scrambling to try to put it all back
together since newton caught covet 19.
yeah i agree totally mike i think they
were on the path
to be an interesting
probably not a playoff team but an
interesting contender this year and who
knows what the future holds but i tend
to think that any team that's down in
the closing minutes by 10 points to the
new york jets probably is going to have
to play for 2021. this has a potential
to be an interesting game
i think though that if i were baltimore
i would be thinking a lot about doing
what i do best and it's weird to think
that you have the mvp quarterback on
your team but to me
i have seen so many times this year
where they get the run going
and it's like
dalvin cook east
you know they are just absolutely
unstoppable a lot of times even without
mark ingram so to me if i were baltimore
i would make sure that i had two ways to
go coming into this game but i think i
think that this is going to be a game
where they run the ball an awful lot
and that brings us to speed round but
where the underdog edition ravens
patriots you mentioned that running game
265 yards against the steelers they lost
the game they shouldn't have lamar
jackson a big part of the running game
mark ingram his status remains in doubt
they've got gus edwards they've got jk
dobbins they've got plenty of guys who
can get it done and the patriots we saw
the last time they faced a great running
team they were run off the field by the
san francisco 49ers so peter i think
that really is a key to this one just
keep it simple do what you do best don't
get don't get intimidated by the fact
that the patriots john harbaugh told me
after the game last look it's still the
patriots we're you know it's still bill
belichick we got a young team that's
still learning how to win we have to
take them seriously and i think they
will and if they do
it it shouldn't matter that it's the
patriots the ravens should be the better
team and they should be able to win the
game easily
i think so but again look they they have
had a lot of fits and starts with their
offense this year mike so i i agree with
you run run run
this week and and just
don't try to do anything too outlandish
and i think they win the game
former patriots quarterback tom brady
now with the tampa bay buccaneers things
were looking good until they weren't
an ugly loss on sunday night the third
worst passer rating of his career the
worst single game passer rating since
november of 2006 he was asked if some
losses like last week's stand out in his
memory more than others serious
now i remember pretty much all the
losses i probably don't remember all the
wins but i definitely remember all the
losses uh
you know they think they all stick with
you because you're competitive and you
want to go out there and play your best
every week and you realize it's a
you know you're not a movie actor where
you get you know six takes when it
doesn't go right you know oh let's let
me do that one over again i messed that
one up you know let's run that back so
you know you're a football player and
you're making split-second decisions and
you always wish man i made every
split-second decision right but
uh that's just not the reality of uh of
the sports
uh peter the uh you know tom brady a
pretty good spirit for a guy that that
uh got embarrassed in prime time yet
again this year after the shellacking on
sunday night football the buccaneers
will what on sunday
wow
i wrote my column the other day i
thought going to carolina and winning
would be a herculean task
i'm not saying they can't be hercules
but i'm saying that i don't really know
right now
if this team can protect an immobile
quarterback well enough to be a powerful
offense you think they should be
but mike we can't we cannot unsee
what happened last sunday night when tom
brady was terrorized back there and so
and and look carolina doesn't have the
pass rush weapons that new orleans has
but carolina's got matt rule you know
and matt rule has pretty much figured
out how to play with everybody this year
including how to come within a play or
two of winning at arrowhead last week so
even without christian mccaffrey which
would be a concerning thing
trend wise if i were uh matt rule
uh and i were joe brady i'd be concerned
about that but i do think
that uh they've got a good chance to
beat uh tampa i didn't i didn't fill in
your blank
i guess if i were pressed to the wall i
would take the bucks but i wouldn't feel
very good about it
i think the bucks absolutely need uh to
re-establish themselves
this week or everything they've done
will feel like smoking mirrors all
season long that it's just something
they've stitched together and ultimately
it falls apart when pressure is applied
to it this is a critical critical game
for them after what happened on sunday
night all right the eagles 3-4-1 coming
off their bye week first place in the
nfc east at the giants two and seven
they met on a thursday night a few weeks
ago after the eagles barely won that
game the rematch will be what peter
surprisingly
really good and i like the giants
and
you know i think one of the things that
we're seeing
is that because there isn't a complete
team or even close to a complete team in
the nfc east you look for units okay and
i start to look for units and i say
the giants defense right now i like them
at this moment in time better than i
like the eagles defense now we'll see if
that pans out but what is so interesting
about this division you could have three
three win teams at the end of this
weekend if washington beats detroit and
the giants beat philadelphia there could
be three teams basically jockeying for
position atop a historically bad
division but i'll just say one other
thing
mike
i found it really really interesting
that brett favre jumped on carson wentz
this week
and
because who's one of brett favre's best
friends in the world
doug peterson
and it isn't like i i am not in i'm not
in any way implying that doug peterson
said oh man i'm down on wentz i'm done
i'm sure i'm positive that he didn't do
that but i'm saying it's just
interesting that farv just felt like hey
you know i would have kept nick foles
over wentz
and did you see wence's reaction it was
basically uh you know whatever
you know like and the translation to me
the translation to me
from carson wentz is hey thanks for
kicking me when i'm down at the worst
point of my career brett i idolized you
as a kid and this is the thanks i get
so i don't know i i i just thought it
was such an odd
uh an odd story this week i i just i
didn't quite get a the timing of it and
the feeling of it that even though i
thought foles was great and wonderful in
time and all that carson wentz was the
future of that team
you know brett favre far better than i
ever will is it possible he's operating
on some higher level of analysis where
he thinks he's doing his friend doug
peterson a favor by lighting a fire
under carson wentz by saying what he
said
anything is possible but i just i don't
think brett and this is i
brett
the one thing about farve that when i
talk to people about farv because
obviously i was very close to him at one
at one point i still am close to him but
not i don't talk to him very much but my
point is that
he's one of the smartest people about
life
and about
different subjects different topics this
is a guy who
watched the nature channel nature
channels and national geographic
incessantly
you know he just he's got a very wide uh
range of interests and so
i just think he said
this is what i think and he said it
i don't think there was anything deep
about it i don't think there was
anything dark about it i think he simply
gave his opinion when asked on a tv show
i would write a very large check for the
privilege of the eavesdropping on a
phone conversation between peter king
and brett favre on the topic of politics
recently i would love i would love to
have heard that we probably would text
we probably would we probably wouldn't
have that conversation
texans at the browns
texans uh uh in some sort of disarray
with everything that happened this week
with the firing of amy palchuk and
that's going to be a mess for them for
weeks to come unrelated to football but
kind of tied to the overall dysfunction
of the team brown's five and three the
browns will hang in the race for a
playoff birthday if what peter
if they can win games just like this one
you know the browns have an incredibly
favorable schedule down the stretch
if they don't make the playoffs
i'm not saying head should roll but
that's
that's
uh that would be a huge huge
uh miss for this franchise at this point
in time
even though i think desean watson is to
be feared any time he steps on the field
i'll be very surprised if the browns
don't take care of business
gonna be cold gonna be windy the running
game is gonna prevail for the browns
they win the games they they're supposed
to win they'll go 10-6 and hopefully
that's enough to get in right now
they're on the outside looking into the
eighth seed but i think if they go 10-6
they will find a way to the postseason
broncos 3-5 raiders 5-3 the raiders will
hang in the race for one of the seven
playoff spots in the afc if they do what
peter
if they continue to play
well
down the stretch of games
when you and look that game last week
could have gone either way okay because
obviously you saw what happened isaiah
johnson is in a uh is is you know it's
the ball is either going to be caught or
it's not going to be caught by the
chargers you know right in the end zone
but
the the raiders are making plays
when past raider teams did not make them
and look you can say whatever you want
about how the chargers blew the game i
get it but
you know at the end of the day it's like
you know did you win the game did you
lose the game and excuses are for losers
so
the the raiders win that game and
they're playing better in the fourth
quarter of games when they absolutely
need to when games are won and lost than
they have in the past
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports